il était opéré hier il peut sortir
aujourd'hui s'il n'est pas douloureux en
fait c'est la ronde du matin on se
réunit tous les vétérinaires de la
journée pour parler des cas hospitalisés
ou pour construire tout ce raccord sur
les cas et qu'on sache tout ce ce qu'on
en fait donc lui c'est un petit chat qui
a été hospitalisé hier soir en fait il a
une obstruction urines être ce petit
chien n'a il est arrivé hier très très
mal et on suspecte fortement une
intoxication ça fait un peu un psycho
actifs et notamment canal cannabis en
fait
lâche l'examen clinique du chien bas
pour voir s'il ya encore des signes des
signes d'intoxication
fénols ou
est-ce que tu ne montes comment tu
marches d'aller mieux
la plupart des intoxications en 24-48
heures ils vont être beaucoup mieux et
on pouvait rentrer chez eux je vous
rappeler pour oscar ça va très bien
aujourd'hui d'accord je vous laisse me
rappeler où appeler l'accueil pour fixer
une heure de sortie voilà bonne journée
à tout à l'heure
et non une partie en consultation du
coup
beaucoup de vers sur son argent
[Musique]
là on a un bloc opératoire et qu'on a
besoin d'anesthésié un animal on va
l'anesthésié là aussi si c'est les
salles de consultation donc elles sont
restés face à face on a une vie entre
les deux pour que les animaux puissent
puissent se voir tout le rigolo de les
voir interagir ici on a une salle de
garde est parce que c'est une ligne qui
fonctionne toute la nuit le dimanche les
jours fériés et vraiment pour être sûr
qu'il n'y a jamais un animal qui va se
retrouver sans devoir de possibilités de
sens s'il ya une urgence en
[Musique]
ami
donc normal on sait les analyses une
numération formule se tiendra bientôt 17
ans donc ouais c'est un chien qui est
très très âgées c'est des périodes où ça
devient quand même quand même importante
parce que le chien perdant un petit peu
la tête il peut pas exprimer aussi bien
ses propriétaires à ses besoins ou
cortile quand il est malade on ressent
moins content parce que j'ai une paire
de sénilité aussi qui s'installe bien
sûr et donc c'est là que ça devient
important d'avoir d'avoir demandé par
matisse chiffre à des paramètres
sanguins pour bat pour évaluer vraiment
l' état de la lima on se rend compte
qu'en fait même si messi est très très
vieux en fait ça va très bien et on
attend la biochimie qui enfin de sortir
pour être plutôt faut bien aimé les
animaux mais un fou bien aimé les gens
que si c'était le système pas les gens
c'est pas la peine qu'on sait c'est
vraiment un métier où effectivement très
grande part de psychologie une grande
part de discussions et de gestion des
menus pour pointer le rôle c'est à la
fois des rassuré mais aussi
aussi l intérêt que des fois on ne peut
pas les rassurer parce que ce soit parce
que c'est grave soit parce qu'on sait
pas parce que des fois on sait pas aussi
a priori et c'est là que c'est la
communication est vraiment vraiment
vraiment importante
ok
non
parce que
[Musique]
elle viendra donc la cdu son objectif
en voit sur l'écran
ok les pistons ne se plaint pas bougé
par les 1 fois
ojjeh hockey un univers et que
donc c'est un chien qui va voyager et il
ya pas mal de formalités affaires faut
que le chien soit identifiée il faut
qu'ils aient un passeport il faut qu'ils
soient vaccinés contre la rage et il va
falloir lui administrer un traitement
contre les parasites
ça tout petit par contre j'avais envie
de j'avais envie de bosser avec les
animaux c'est plate à dire mais je
trouve toujours que c'est des êtres
profondément gentil des animaux et
authentique en fait ce que c'est à dire
qu' il n'y aura jamais même s'ils sont
même s'ils peuvent être agressifs c'est
de l'agression par par la peur parce
qu'ils ont passé des attaques n'ont pas
de pain pas de jugement un pas de côté
[Musique]
on
comment cela
mieux c'est
on sent
[Musique]
très bien mais on sentait bien et où
l'on tue
c'est facile et c'est comme ça que j'ai
trouvé en fait c'est surtout les mauvais
termes et les charges
sont pas là il faut les transports s'est
passé pour le mettre dans la boîte du
coup
alors qu'est ce qui lui arrive
[Musique]
très bien c'est déjà fini très bien le
plus difficile dans le métier c'est le
rythme et c'est un métier qui prend
énormément de temps en moyenne il est 20
heures quand on repart c'est pour
certains mais bon passons encore c'est
encore plus tard nous ça fait des
journées qui sont très très longue une
pareille voir s'il ya pas mal pas mal
d'émotions mais c'est sûr que parfois
c'est un peu un peu moins de temps pour
la maîtriser
rapidement empreinte merci mais tu dis
qu'il fallait mettre alors des à l'aise
dans l'appartement bah ouais il ya des
gens qui font ça et moi j'ai pas pour du
tout parce que effectivement du coup
c'est la france à le lui apprend à faire
dans l'appartement
plus de conseiller un peu de l'épaule et
terre pour agir contre eux on leur dit
au niveau comportemental et c'est alors
vraiment conséquences et des questions
d'ordre simple comme ça si c'est des
problèmes comportementaux plus a lancé
bayadh et des vétérinaires qui sont
spécialisés dans le comportement vous
voir des comportementaliste qui sont pas
forcément vétérinaire qui peuvent gérer
bien mieux bien mieux ça en fait je
compare ça un peu à un psychologue en
humaine il ya des choses ou médecin
général voire très bien aider les gens
pour les questions d'ordre dans très
général dès que ça devient un petit peu
plus un petit peu plus spécialisés l'a
fait c'est le rôle du psychologue du
comportement thalys du couple en chine
au
micro c'est vermifuge on fait tous les
mois jusqu'à l'âge de six mois et après
tous les trois mois
de rien
[Musique]
c'est les grosses journées sans métier
je suis et à l'heure c'était pas à cette
époque passionné c'est pas possible il
faut être passionné à la fois parce que
tu fais avec les animaux il faut être
passionné aussi dans la dans la relation
avec les ans
[Musique]